hey guys it's Wednesday October 19th I'm
Mary and you're watching gamespot news
if yesterday's GS news was like the
party and today's is kind of like the
hangover not very good because today we
found out that the Darksiders remaster
is delayed that's right THQ Nordic
announced today that Darksiders more
mastered addition the remaster of the
original Darksiders will not launch on
october 25th as previously announced the
publisher confirmed the game has been
delayed to november 22nd for physical
and digital copies both on ps4 and xbox
one the remastered edition will launch
that date digitally for Wii U with a
physical version to follow at a later
stage besides the delay not much else
has changed the twenty-dollar warm
mastered edition aims to improve upon
the original 2010 action-adventure game
in a number of ways first up it's going
to run at native 1080p on consoles it
also hits 60 FPS on ps4 xbox one and pc
although Wii U is limited to 30 frames
players can also expect better shadow
rendering quality and new post
processing effects among other
improvements more bummer news the
developer behind Sleeping Dogs has shut
down and their current game isn't even
for sale anymore united front games who
you might know from sleeping dogs closed
its doors their first title was
modnation racers a ps3 exclusive kart
racing game had a large focus on
user-generated content then they made
2012 sleeping dogs which is what they
were pretty much known for and then
after that littlebigplanet karting
several port projects and the canceled
triad wars the vancouver-based studio
was in the midst of developing smash and
grab an early access game that was on
steam it featured players ransacking
stores and looting items as of now you
can't buy smash and grab it was free
this past weekend as part of a promotion
on Steam players could pay a discounted
price of 17 bucks and then they could
keep playing after Sunday it's unclear
what's going to happen a smash-and-grab
and its players now that it's no longer
for sale we've contacted united front
and we're going to keep you updated when
we hear back
do you ever wonder what would happen if
you combined the powers of Pokemon go
with Sun and Moon besides magic because
it might actually happen there's a demo
out now for Pokemon Sun and Moon on the
Nintendo 3ds and it's got people
thinking what would happen if there was
a crossover gamespot's Justin hey wold
spoke to Nintendo's junichi Masuda a
long time developer and composer on the
Pokemon franchise who's currently
working as a producer on sun and moon
when asked whether the team is still
working on bringing Pokemon Sun Moon and
Pokemon go together he said it's
definitely not off the table we're still
thinking about the best way to establish
this kind of connectivity and what the
best timing will be first we just want
people to enjoy Sun and Moon after they
come out then we'll keep working on
ideas to best accomplish that we have
the full interview up with even more
insight from masuda as well as Sun Moon
director Shigeru ohmori regarding the
upcoming 3ds title legendary Pokemon and
the continuing Pokemon go crazy you can
find it on gamespot and that's all I
have for you today but check back
tomorrow for more gamespot news